[Music]
[Narrator:] In the short time since the discovery of sulfonamides and then penicillin,
the world has witnessed greater progress
in the control of infectious diseases in man
and animals
than has previously occurred in medical history.
The scene is changing with such rapidity
that what is known today is frequently invalid
tomorrow.
The practitioner must ever keep abreast of
late clinical evidence
in order to exercise sound judgment in employing
antimicrobial agents available to him.
It is the purpose of this film, therefore,
to say, in effect,
this we know, but there is more to learn.
Since the introduction of broad-spectrum antibiotics,
the dramatic changes in morbidity and mortality
statistics
have established antimicrobial agents
as one of the major avenues of attack against
infectious diseases.
Tetracycline, demethylchlortetracycline, chlortetracycline,
oxytetracycline, chloramphenicol, streptomycin,
the sulfonamides, or penicillin have been
shown to be effective
in the control of brucellosis, pertussis,
Rocky Mountain Spotted Fever,
scarlet fever, tuberculosis, tularemia,
typhoid and paratyphoid fever, and typhus.
But valuable as antibiotics are, they cannot
replace accurate diagnosis,
therapeutic judgment, and skilled surgery.
Infections must be properly treated and anatomic
abnormalities corrected.
Even though many infectious diseases may be
controlled by antimicrobial agents,
many others will either not respond to them,
or of are such nature that it is desirable
to prevent their occurrence by immunization.
Passive immunization against these diseases
may be of value in decreasing the severity
of the symptoms.
Combined immunization against diphtheria, pertussis, and tetanus
should be started at one to two months of
age.
Polio vaccine may be started at the same time
as the other immunizations.
The initial course should consist of three
injections of triple antigen,
given at intervals of not less than one month
and preferably not more than three months.
It is recommended that a fourth injection
be given
a year following the third injection.
Injections should consist of .5 ml made into
either the deltoid
or the gluteus maximus muscles.
Injections should not be made more than once
at the same site during the primary course
of immunization.
Those states having the largest number of
diphtheria cases
are shown in the darkest color.
Reported cases of diphtheria, as might be
expected,
have shown a steady decrease during the last
15 years.
Diphtheria infection sources are discharges
and secretions
from the surfaces of the nose, throat, nasal
pharynx, skin,
and other lesions of infected persons.
A diagnostic test consists of culture rapid
growth of bacteria in four hours
on horse serum-impregnated cotton swab kept
at 37 degrees centigrade
in Loeffler's or Tellurite media.
Strains isolated should be tested for virulence.
For older children and adults, diphtheria
toxoid as a single antigen
is indicated in reduced dosage for primary
immunization and booster injections.
In primary immunization of children in the
preschool age,
the use of diphtheria toxoid alone is recommended
only when there is some specific contra-indication
to the use of the triple antigens.
For individuals over 10 years old, diphtheria
toxoid in doses
exceeding two hundredths to five hundredths
ml
should not be given without a preliminary
Schick test,
together with a Moloney or [Zella?] toxoid
sensitivity test as a control.
For primary immunization of children less
than 10 years of age,
give three intramuscular injections of five
tenths ml
at intervals of at least one month, but preferably
not more than four months.
For individuals more than 10 years of age
who are Schick-positive reactors
with negative sensitivity tests,
the primary immunization course is the same
as for children under 10.
Individuals showing positive reactions to
both the Schick test
and a toxoid sensitivity test should not
be given further toxoid.
Negative reactors to both the Schick and toxoid
sensitivity tests
require no further toxoid as the tests themselves
serve as small boosters.
But if immunization practices including recall
injections at three-year intervals
are carried out as previously outlined,
repeated use of the Schick test to determine
individual susceptibility seems unwarranted.
Passive immunity may be obtained for about
10 days with diphtheria antitoxin
in doses of from 1,000 to 2,000 units intramuscularly.
A careful history and adequate sensitivity
testing
should be done before any animal serum product
is administered.
However, serum sickness may occur in individuals
who had no sensitivity prior to serum administration.
Whooping cough sources of infection are from discharges
from pharyngeal and bronchial mucus membranes of infected persons.
Pertussis vaccine as a single antigen is indicated
for attempted rapid primary protection of
infants
in the presence of epidemics, for primary
immunization
of children who have been inoculated against
diphtheria and tetanus,
and for recall injections following exposure.
Pertussis vaccine, saline suspended, is useful
in attempted rapid protection
of exposed individuals during epidemics.
A total of 12 NIH units divided into three
equal doses
should be injected subcutaneously at intervals
of one week.
Pertussis vaccine, alum-precipitated or aluminum
phosphate- or hydroxide-absorbed
are preferred for infants less than six months
when there is no need for rapid protection,
and when he has already received
diphtheria and tetanus inoculations,
or a contra-indication to the triple antigen
exists.
Twelve NIH units should be injected intramuscularly
in three equal doses at intervals of four
to six weeks.
Recall injections of four NIH units should
be given a year later, then in two years,
and thereafter every three years if the danger
of whooping cough infection exists.
Against tetanus, active immunization is indicated in all children,
adults subject to abrasions, and in adults
who are exposed to frequent accidents
where tetanus spores may contaminate the wound.
Primary immunization is obtained by two intramuscular
injections
of .5 ml each of alum-precipitated or aluminum
hydroxide-adsorbed tetanus toxoid
at an interval of between one and four months.
Recall injections are advised in one year
and every five to 10 years thereafter,
or after potential exposure.
The effectiveness of emergency boosters is
dependent on the time relationship
between the injection and the potential development
of infection
so that toxoid alone may not be adequate.
When the individual already has had previous
toxoid,
added protection is afforded if, in addition
to the booster,
he is given hyperimmune gamma globulin
in the muscles of a different extremity using
the usual precautions.
Where the possibility of gas gangrene coexists,
a gas gangrene antitoxin is also available.
Although smallpox is endemic in various parts of the world,
it has virtually been eliminated from the
United States.
Individuals suspected of smallpox should be isolated strictly,
pending definite diagnosis.
Diagnosis on clinical evidence is generally
possible
and preventive measures should be instituted
without waiting for results of laboratory
tests.
Primary vaccination is recommended in the
first year of life
unless the child is not thriving or is suffering
from allergic eczema
or dermatologic disorders, with revaccination
every three years thereafter.
The multiple pressure method should be used
over the skin of the left deltoid muscle
or the posterior aspect of the arm over the
triceps muscle.
These are the stages of successful primary
vaccination:
maculation, second day;
papulation, fourth day;
vesiculation, sixth day;
pustulation, tenth day;
scabbing or crusting, thirteenth day;
scarring, twentieth day.
This is an early or immediate reaction.
Tuberculin-negative individuals who are potentially exposed to tuberculosis
can be immunized with the BCG vaccine.
Tuberculin sensitivity is determined by means of the intracutaneous injection
of OT or PPD or by the use of the tuberculin
tine test shown here.
As soon as possible after completing the tuberculin
test,
.1 ml of material equal to .1 mg BCG vaccine
should be injected intracutaneously
as superficially as possible over the deltoid
muscle.
BCG vaccine should not be given to infants
who are markedly underweight at birth
or who are premature, nor should it be given
when the person is suffering from infectious
diseases.
Although the vaccine may be given at the same
time with other antigens,
it should never be administered simultaneously
with smallpox vaccination.
Typhoid fever sources of infection are the
feces and urine of patients and carriers.
Immunization is indicated for residents in
rural areas
of the United States and Canada where the
disease is prevalent.
For adults, a total dose of 1 ml standard
typhoid vaccine should be given
in two equal doses one to four weeks apart,
by the subcutaneous route.
Infants less than one year of age should receive
correspondingly small doses.
Sharp febrile reactions are not uncommon.
Recall injections of .1 ml intracutaneously
every one to two years depending on probability
of exposure.
Active immunization against scarlet fever,
streptococcal pharyngitis, and arrecipolis
is no longer attempted since the advent of
effective chemotherapy of streptococcal diseases.
Adequate treatment of streptococcal infections
with one of the penicillins
has become most important, since the development
of acute glomerulonephritis
and rheumatic fever may be prevented in this
way.
Passive immunization has been practiced in
the past,
but the advent of antibiotics makes the procedure
unnecessary.
In certain circumstances, it may be desirable
to culture exposed individuals
and treat those with positive cultures,
especially if the index case developed nephritis.
Antimicrobial therapy should be seriously
considered
for administration to hospitalized patients
as well as to close contacts of cases.
The importance of careful investigation and
adequate treatment
of any contact having a history of rheumatic
fever is well-known.
Prophylactic use of penicillin and other antimicrobial
agents is often necessary.
Satisfactory immunity against poliomyelitis
has been conferred
in several large mass vaccination programs
by the administration of two feedings
of trivalent Sabin vaccine at intervals of
one to two months
or by the feeding of monovalent vaccine at
intervals of one month.
The precise need for boosters has not yet
been clearly shown,
although recent evidence indicates that it
may be prudent to administer
booster feedings to children three years after
the primary series.
In the case of measles, passive immunization may be attempted
when conditions render it advisable, such
as in infants under 12 months,
children ill with or closely exposed to other
diseases
such as tuberculosis and rheumatic fever.
Killed vaccine or gamma globulin is advised for such patients.
Passive immunization may be used in institutions to avoid epidemics.
Clinical experience indicates that .02 ml
of human gamma globulin
per pound of body weight is satisfactory for modification,
while .1 ml per pound of body weight is considered
sufficient for prevention.
Passive immunization against, or attenuation
of, infectious hepatitis
may be attempted in cases where infection
is likely
or exposure is known to have occurred.
Human gamma globulin injected subcutaneously
or intramuscularly
is thought to give protection for six to eight
weeks.
Effective dosage range has been found to lie
between
.01 ml and .06 ml per pound of body weight.
Temporary immunity can be obtained by injection of gamma globulin
prepared from donors who have been hyperimmunized with mumps vaccine.
Active immunization can be accomplished
by means of subcutaneous injections of inactivated vaccines.
The recent attenuation of the mumps virus
may make routine immunization of infants and
children possible.
Brucellosis infections in man should be prevented
through pasteurization of all dairy products,
separation of hogs from milk-producing cattle,
and veterinary measures to eliminate brucellosis
from cattle and hogs.
Active immunization against Rocky Mountain Spotted Fever
is advised only for individuals working in
highly endemic areas.
Protection from vaccination is not long-lasting.
Stimulating doses must be given annually to
maintain a high level of protection.
Three subcutaneous injections of .5 ml each
of inactivated Cox yolk-sac vaccine
should be given at five- to seven-day intervals.
The case you have seen here is typical of
the disease.
Active immunization against tularemia is advised
only for laboratory workers
and those handling wild rabbits and other
susceptible animals.
Individuals should be skin-tested prior to
vaccination
[Line graph of reported cases of tularemia,
1950-1965]
using one to 1,000 dilution of vaccine and
saline.
Positive reactors should not be immunized
as they may develop severe reactions.
Negative reactors should be given three doses
of vaccine subcutaneously
at two-day intervals in the following amounts:
.1 ml, .5 ml and .5 ml.
Rabies in man has decreased in recent years
to the point that only six cases have been
reported since 1961.
After exposure to rabies, patients with bites
about the trunk or extremities
with no extensive tissue damage should be
given rabies vaccine
in .5 ml doses subcutaneously daily for 14
days.
In cases of extensive tissue damage, multiple
bites,
injuries about the head, or where treatment
has been delayed,
2.5 ml doses should be given daily for the
next seven days.
Anti-rabies serum is a useful adjunct to therapy
with rabies vaccine
for the prevention of rabies,
but should not be used as a substitute for
the vaccine.
It is of vital importance that the dog be
caught.
If it dies after showing signs of rabies,
its brain should be examined for the presence
of Negri bodies or fluorescent antibodies.
Cholera, an important disease in the United
States until 1893,
is now confined to southeastern Asia, China, and the near east.
A killed vaccine is available for people entering endemic zones,
but the immunity conferred thereby is of relatively short duration.
Immunization is obtained in adults with a
.5 ml injection of
inactivated cholera vaccine subcutaneously
followed a week later by an injection of 1
ml.
For children under 11 the following doses
are recommended.
Booster injections of from .1 ml to 1 ml according
to age may be required every six months.
Plague occurs in wild rodents and/or in man
in many parts of the world.
In the United States, the endemicity in wild
rodents is slowly moving eastward.
Human cases are rare,
about 500 cases having been reported since
1900.
This is a bubo showing extensive necrosis
and bubo pasteurella pestis in large numbers.
Plague immunization may be obtained in adults
with a .5 ml injection of plague vaccine
subcutaneously, followed by 1 ml given 7 to 28 days later.
For children under 11, three subcutaneous injections
at 7- to 10-day intervals should be given as shown.
Re-immunization may be required not more often than every four to six months
where plague is a hazard.
Basic typhus immunization may be obtained in adults
by a 1 ml subcutaneous injection of typhus vaccine
followed by a second injection of 1 ml given in one to three weeks
and a third in the same amount a year later.
Children under 11 should be given equal doses
of vaccine one to three weeks apart.
The dose for a six-month old child to a two-year
old should be
.1 ml; three to six years .25 ml; seven to
ten years .5 ml.
Boosters are from .12 ml to 1 ml according
to age
should be given annually to retain immunity.
This is the reported distribution of human
cases of yellow fever.
Cases in jungle animals are important
because they may under certain circumstances
feed urban epidemics among man.
Immunization for all age groups is obtained
by a single subcutaneous injection of .5 ml
of a
one to 10 dilution of concentrated yellow
fever vaccine.
Containing an attenuated strain of virus,
a similar dose as a booster may be required
every six years.
These are intranuclear inclusion bodies in
liver cells.
The administration of an injection for immunization
against an infectious disease is a simple
procedure,
but to avoid infecting the patient,
it is essential that asepsis be maintained
at all times.
Store vaccines and serum products under refrigeration.
Reconstitute live attenuated vaccines just
prior to use.
Rubber stoppers of the antigen containers
must be disinfected.
The physician should be familiar with recent
medical literature
and with package literature before administering
any biological product,
and every precaution must be taken
for the prevention and arrest of untoward
reactions.
Serum therapy should be employed only when
definitely indicated
and only when the physician is equipped adequately
to combat such reactions as may occur.
[Music]